mais pour normande est rentré de britney
spears britney spears qu'on pourra voir
les photos brett hester pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent qui est en train de
péter un plomb voilà voilà voilà
instagram de sept femmes qui selon hugo
mallo donc j'ai parfaitement équilibré
accésss allawi voilà bah moi je suis
désolé mais le jour où vous voyez poser
comme ça avec un diamant
[Rires]
ou quand
[Applaudissements]
la danse c'est pour tp
mpc suffit monsieur c'est un piège à
guetter d'histoire
elle c'est justement beac même savait
qu'elle s'est justifié après suite à ces
photos est forcément ou commentaires
violents qu'elle a reçu sa meuf a quand
même écrit sur les réseaux ok tout le
monde je pose le corps nu en polynésie
française mais c'est juste pour montrer
que je suis une femme libre et rebelle
voilà l'explication devant
une famille mon petit appel ou pas c'est
pas le giron du jour
j'ai toujours été une femme libre moins
bien moins bien gaulée que ça et roubaix
oui mais alors dame en rose est très
belle et vous étiez aussi très bonne
absolument oui quand j'ai vu le trou
vaches étaient comestibles série n'aime
pas je dis ça mais c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai mais blessé notre dame en politique
vous pourriez vous être un diamant
à jouer moi je vois hugo qui est
vachement gédéon fait d'habitat leur
match et c'est sa vie et
tu te dis ouais en fait je t'avais prévu
un petit cadeau et je voulais écrire là
mais maintenant ça tombe mal du coup ça
tombe mal rock c'était le diable
c'était la même chose que le diable pour
toi ton cadeau c'est un bijou direct
avait refait les mêmes photos avec le
diamant
prochaine ces décès portent à neuf le
diamant non non non le climatologue à
doullens qui le lendemain
tu vois ça commence tu pas de 5 alors et
sap a choqué tout le monde y avait 3
millions de vues en trois jours comme la
symétrie
bien sûr tu très bien
c'est autant faire match nul ça on peut
pas lui enlever c'est pas classe c'est à
dire guère les foules de gens qui n'est
jamais revenu et les photos sont jaugés
pas vrai la ceast éthique ça honnêtement
c'est pas que ça veut pas dire qu'elle a
un problème psychologique chérissez on
peut mettre tout le temps mettre en
corrélation défense civile sur son
instinct il à paul tout le temps alors
il fait ça il fait bouger un peg de pain
des salles prend un air inspiré tu
regarde beaucoup c'est story
[Applaudissements]
ma tête mon coeur tu as is your way sur
britney il faut quand même rappeler
qu'elle a eu 40 ans au mois de décembre
dernier quand même un âge charnière
hommes ou femmes confondus voilà et
peut-être qu'elle a envie de nous
rappeler que ses courbes n'ont pas bougé
qu'elle est toujours dans la force de
l'âge
c'est une belle femme comme avant voilà
tout cela on a une approche exclusive de
mais c'est surtout deborah oui/non
karine
ne seront pas de prénoms sont à ces
points un début d'alzheimer et que c'est
juste que elle elle en train de préparer
un gros truc dans deux mois a priori
elle sortirait un featuring avec eminem
mais non ouais avec eminem ce sera un
énorme ouais c'est vrai n'at-on partout
depuis c'est le sun qui a révélé ça elle
ne sortirait dans deux mois et elle le
ferait sur le plateau d'oprah winfrey
dans le great une intel va revenir
regardons les reventes ont explosé à
nouveau depuis le choix
il peut pas la comparer à loana mais ça
n'a vraiment aucun rapport avec la
connaît d'abord oui mais il ya un canard
américaine très sérieux qui a écrit que
de toute façon bientôt je serai de
nouveau sur la coupe de mecs parce
qu'elle ne peut pas se gérer tout seul
mais là
la raison et c'est le mâle dominant et
non mais là bas il est pas mal dominant
quand on suit moi je le suis il fait pas
du tout justement gilles c'est moi qui
la gère et ou non il est tout doux il a
suivi ses limites il suit ses délires il
a filmé à moitié à poil voir la vidéo il
pourrait finir par être la figure tout
le match et il a filmé comment son coach
de sport et gaming balle par mois tu
penses de québec ils ont fait ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il n'a pas l'air très
brillant quoi on voit où il a joué bien
compte ainsi il a l'air c'est bien ce
qu'on dit qu'à toi nouveau surtout clair
mettre quelqu'un est intelligente elle a
mis en vente sa maison pour apparemment
de 9 millions de dollars alors en photo
nue sur le coup et la maison dorée des
sciences animales un acheteur cherche
déjà le mec pour écrire son bouquin
parce qu'évidemment l'aura jamais le
temps des rires sinon c'est votre métier
qui est sur les rangs pour le racheter a
fait une proposition pour acheter cette
maison à 9,90 dollars et pour de vrai
d'un spectacle laurent regarde ne s'est
pas une vanne à dicaprio non pas loin
une star américaine gigantesque une
femme
jeune n'diaye
pardon pardon oui juste une dernière
chose toujours spécialiste des états
unis on voit sur ces news ou parler ces
passionnés n'ont pas déprécié de cette
main fogel il faut pas l'oublier d'aidé
quoi et on
avait fait bien sûr qu'on est sûr qu'on
aime beaucoup mais pas pas le samedi et
est du coup qu'est ce qu'on pense de
britney spears aux etats unis
aujourd'hui justement à divise elle est
très vivante mais elle est née c'était
la fille d'à côté en anglais
mais voilà et en fait là elle a passé sa
vie en fait à faire un peu ça va essayer
de sortir de ce rôle là pour essayer de
montrer qu'elle est autre chose là
évidemment elle le fait peut-être avec
moins de talent que le faisait madonna
par exemple le problème c'est vrai qu'au
moment où elle est plus sûre qu elle
devrait montrer qu'elle est
psychologiquement confrères scène ses
photos c'est vrai que c'est pas très
esthétique et il n'en fait pas la jolie
non non et c'est vrai que beaucoup se
disent bon moi je vous dis ça sent pas
bon tout ça